>>> WE SPEND SO MUCH ON THINGS
WE NEED.
WHAT ABOUT THE THINGS WE WANT?
>> I WANT TO BETTER MYSELF.
>> I WANT TO TREAT MYSELF.
>> I WANT TO ENJOY MYSELF.
>> THE THINGS WE BUY TO INVEST
IN OUR LIVES.
>> OIL PAINTS.
>> AN INSTRUMENT TO LEARN.
>> AN ELLIPTICAL.
>> THE THINGS THAT AREN'T ABOUT
OUR TO-DO LIST BUT ABOUT OUR
BUCKET LIST.
>> ROSETTA STONE ITALIAN.
>> ICE CREAM MAKER.
>> ROLLER SKATES.
>> YOU'VE BEEN HOME EIGHT MONTHS
AND YOU DIDN'T TOUCH THEM ONCE.
NOW YOU HAVE TO SELL THEM.
WITH EBAY.
>> I SPENT $80 ON EMBROIDERY
EQUIPMENT BACK IN MARCH.
BUT THEN I JUST STARED AT MY
PHONE, AND I LOOKED UP, AND NOW
IT'S OCTOBER.
>> I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO COOK
MORE, SO I BOUGHT A $400 CHEF'S
KNIFE I ONLY USE TO OPEN AMAZON
PACKAGES.
>> GUITARS HURT.
NO ONE TELLS YOU THAT.
I DON'T LIKE FEELING HURT.
>> YOU ALWAYS WISHED FOR MORE
FREE TIME SO YOU COULD GET
AROUND TO THEM.
AND THEN YOU WERE QUARANTINED.
AND INSTEAD OF READING "THE
ODYSSEY," YOU WATCHED EVERY
EPISODE OF "SELLING SUNSET.
>> SO THIS IS A HOUSE.
>> SO NOW YOU KNOW.
>> I THOUGHT I WANTED TO LEARN
HOW TO BOX TO CONNECT WITH MY
DECEASED FATHER.
TURNS OUT I WANT TO LAY ON THE
COUCH AND WATCH WOMEN LOSE THEIR
DAMN MINDS.
>> GO AHEAD AND SELL THAT STUFF.
NOT TO WORRY.
IF YOU FIND YOURSELF BUYING
SOMETHING NEW ON OUR SITE,
EBAY'S MAKING IT EASIER THAN
EVER TO FAIL HARD WITH OUR NEW
SERVICE, PREBAY.
WHERE WE INTERCEPT YOUR LATEST
OVERLY OPTIMISTIC PURCHASE AND
TAKE IT RIGHT BACK BEFORE YOU
EVEN OPEN IT.
LOOK, YOU HAD YOUR CHANCE.
AND ALL THE TIME IN THE WORLD.
DON'T BE SHY.
IF YOU ADMIT THAT IT'S UNUSED,
YOU'LL MAKE MORE MONEY.
EBAY.
THIS COMMERCIAL DOESN'T APPLY TO
YOU IF YOU WORKED OR HAD KIDS.
>> OH, MY PASTA MAKER'S HERE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]